[Music]
just you guys know who blackrock is
yes are we gonna talk about that
[ __ ] calling entitled millennial
i'm sorry i just burnt it out okay all
right let's take a look what's black
rock
blackrock is a oh is it an investment
firm basically
it's like a conglomerate blackstone
right because there's black stone too
yeah they're different than barcelona
they're not the same there's also black
they're different right but they're
different companies but they're all
associated because i know that blackrock
was um
buying up a ton of [ __ ] listing
and you know like even in like vegas and
like california so like they're the guys
also that's coming in
and buying out homes cash over asking so
like
this thing has been going around right
and then when i looked into it i'm like
who's all these rich people coming in um
like is it for it's for like development
like they're just like buying a
gentrifying area so they just want like
all the real estate or like is it some
[ __ ] that they want to [ __ ] us over i
don't know what the details of their
strategy is
but they're buying up a lot of [ __ ]
land and a lot of [ __ ] real estate
real estate a lot and i have it i think
it has something to do with the low
interest rates and and and and the
knowing that the fiat is going down in
value that they're just trying to uh
hedge it
like everyone else is trying to do
everyone i mean like [ __ ] bill gates
he's the number one private owner of
like farm real estate right now so
even like zillow and like redfern was
doing that yeah they'll just come out
and straight up yeah they got trouble
for them they'll just buy it and they'll
just own massive amounts of land but um
i found out also that blackrock was
giving uh they said basically for each
home they're offering an extra 100k on
top
cash so then like it just beat out
everybody out of the market so like
let's say like you know young families
in la right average home here is still
700k well now it's probably like eight
or nine
but this was two years ago two years ago
average home here 700k right so imagine
like just like i mean like you and you
nick like you you and tiff like
you're married like you know maybe
starting a family soon or whatever like
how possible is it
for anyone to [ __ ] own a home here
even with decent jobs so even if you got
the 700 000 house now you have to pay
property taxes you have to pay
increasing gas prices like there's so
much cost we know so many people that
have been looking for a home to buy in
this past like two year span
and same issues keep happening somebody
comes in
uh is giving an offer
hundred thousand dollars way over and
then they lose it every single time and
then same thing happening in honolulu
san francisco san jose like all the
major cities right so
what i found out is there's a couple of
things right so there's already a lot of
rich people in la
california is what like the fifth
biggest economy worldwide like just
right behind like china japan germany
like it's like a nation just california
it was its own country so we so like
locals are trying to compete against
foreign investors rich people already in
california who wants to like i have all
this extra money now i got to buy real
estate because my dollar if i leave it
in the bank account is going to go down
[ __ ] companies like you know
blackrock and other investment groups
not only that contract groups so like
let's say all of us we you know we're
just small time contractors we build
homes together what a perfect time
like right now when the interest rate is
low let's just go buy up some homes
you put in a hundred thousand dollars
each we buy a cash and then we fix it up
and then we flip it and we keep doing
this over and over loans are so cheap
right now right why wouldn't you do it
and then you have old la families that's
just been around and you know like the
longer you're here typically the more
wealth you have right because you've
been here for so long it's like grandma
great grandpa bought a house and then
you know grandpa bought a house and then
dad bought a house so now you have three
homes in your family you know and then
like you can buy another one so i think
like all that [ __ ] combined to like
being able to like being you know it's
just difficult for people like us to
just
get money and
and people like us it's not even like
we you we actually have a little bit
more money than the average population
but we still it's still [ __ ] crazy
well especially because the interest
rates are so low right now it's kind of
a rush to towards the exit because
they've already announced they're going
to raise a quarter
like every quarter like a quarter
percent like six times this year or
something yeah they just they just
raised it up by half yeah you so you've
been saving for a house and maybe this
was your time oh my god now everyone's
running towards the door trying to get
their [ __ ] loan approved so they can
buy their house before this thing spikes
yeah if annie doesn't move to vegas by
this year it's not gonna happen ever so
what's [ __ ] up is
this
this
this son of a [ __ ] clock's ticking yeah
so this is blackrock's president right
his name is rob capito he says that
inflation's having dramatic effects in
the economy with an entire generation
now learning now learning what it means
to suffer from from shortages he says
for the first time this generation is
going to go to the store not be able to
get what they want and we have a very
entitled generation that has never had
to sacrifice
what a [ __ ] load of [ __ ] huh
he's out here this is what i don't
understand he's out here
[ __ ] buying up all the goddamn houses
and then so out pricing everybody and
saying well you're entitled they are the
world's largest asset manager with about
10 trillion in client assets and
investments
he's he's putting his finger on the
garden hose and he's going yeah
everybody you can't not everybody gets a
drink
[Laughter]
we have limited resources what a cool
guy so out of touch
and also what i don't get too is um
so gas prices right the price of uh
barrel for oil right now
is actually cheaper than it was like
seven years ago or something
so
it doesn't i saw a chart of it people
were like why why is it why is this
happening where like let's say seven
years ago the price of barrel i'm just
gonna throw this number out there it's
not the actual number but just for
example 10 bucks right so if it's 10
bucks and then the gas prices are
actually cheaper back then
why is the gas
uh barrel like eight bucks but it's more
expensive now
so it's like the wholesale price of gas
is cheaper but we're charging higher and
i'm like what the [ __ ] is going on is
that inflation is that just because they
want to charge more they're gonna do it
i don't know buy that one probably that
one it's like the second
the oil barrels uh cost more suddenly
it's like you have to make everybody the
natural consumer pay more and then the
second second you realize that wait a
minute consumers can pay this much even
though the oil prices go down you're
kind of like well they can pay this much
but it's a cartel it's a controlled it's
a controlled supply it's a fixed supply
by the saudis right so we all know it
it's like opec is controlling the supply
so they get to really determine how much
is released and how much they they
constrict so
that's directly correlated it's it's
them
no but what he's saying is even though
the oil barrels are going down in price
yeah and that's what we're paying for
them the gas stations down the corner is
still charging retail is higher than
this yeah yeah but that's why it's the
same price right so it's like the same
it's the same price um as like you're
saying a couple years ago and all that
stuff but then by the time that you know
they get to factor in all the war stuff
mm-hmm by the time they're shipping oil
over here well plus dude what's going on
with the with the petrol dollars crazy
right now like basically saudi arabia
and or russia are pressuring
all these countries to say hey we're not
going to take u.s dollars anymore for
oil you're going to have to pay us in
ruble wow and so and and that's
happening right now russia just did that
to germany they're like hey you want to
oh you want oil guess what you pay us in
rubles now whoa and so then
now germany's like okay well we were
using us dollars before so now it's like
okay we're not going to use the dollar
we have to buy more rubles which is
strengthening russia's economy is going
with uh india india and russia too
because india wants to keep their
business open with russia so they have
to like go around the sanctions which is
really just going to perpetuate the u.s
dollar value
you know china and russia just did this
like last week
they say the new world order why do
people keep saying that new world order
comes from saying it bite and saying new
world it's different new world order
like i'm pretty sure china russia is
talking about something else different
from [ __ ] biden we're talking about
old new world order i know right yeah
man plus the state of california they
tax the [ __ ] out of the pump right so so
you know maybe in vegas it's like a
dollar less yeah it's a dollar less
because they're charging the tax so you
know what's crazy so hawaii which is a
[ __ ] island in the middle of the
ocean has cheaper gas than la how the
[ __ ] is that possible it's direct from
uh
you get the volcano gas well dude did
you guys ever know people with gas
stations
uh oh mike songs dead yeah so there's a
lot of money that goes into the
maintenance and they it's like really
required to do these weird maintenance
things and pay these other companies to
come in and do these inspections that's
the wreck and and then if those go up
then so does the gas price and i heard
they only make like a center
to ten cents
yeah so it's the gift shops it's like
the the gas is what gets you in there
and if you buy like it's like a movie
theater type of thing you know like
burrito get the food yeah that was
actually exactly something that happened
at my son's dad's gas station i remember
when uh mike was helping his dad to add
all the [ __ ] convenience stuff like
the the sodas the drinks the snacks
pretty much the concessions
yeah and then that was what ends up
changing the business model wow
it's pretty crazy though but it blows my
mind that
he would be so out of touch just
thinking that millennials and gen z are
so um entitled i don't think he's out of
touch i think he's perfectly in touch
you know what i mean like he's talking
about scarcity inflation but then he's
purchasing all the real estate creating
scarcity inflation i think he's [ __ ]
fully in touch but i think that's just
the difference is that also i guess like
the purest definition of like free
market capitalism where it's like you
versus me
and yes you're entitled so i'm gonna
rush forward it's up to you if you're
gonna earn money to buy that house if
not i'm gonna crush your ass a little
bit this is the game that we're playing
a little bit right yeah but it's almost
like
talking [ __ ] to the person
who can't afford normal goods and
services punching down by saying by
saying like huh it's not new either like
this is what they always do yeah
remember when they blamed all the poor
people for freddie may and freddie mac
and they're like all these stupid [ __ ]
got loans that couldn't afford well no
[ __ ] you stupid idiots you can't pay
your bills hey guess what you got to pay
your bills okay poor people that's what
they remember basically and they were
doing predatory loans and they're
defaulting yeah making money off of
every sign up and they don't give a [ __ ]
if they can pay for the loan or not
they're just approving a proven approval
ridiculous high-risk loans and then
they're going well you're supposed to
pay you [ __ ] dumbass i like that
voice
model with anything where you where
someone's getting in commish for the
dotted line
any business where that's what you get
that dude is gonna move papers
i did that [ __ ] with some [ __ ] cell
phones in 2001
people couldn't afford it their credit i
would pull it up go oh [ __ ] well hey
just sign here man
i was like the [ __ ]
man
fargo scams right yeah you had to just
sign dead people up for credit cards
ensued you see it happen all the time in
every business yeah it's like an
encouraged behavior which is [ __ ]
crazy it's down to the bottom line yeah
and then at the top of it like it's like
the quote that he said is it's just
inciting like blame all directions and
that's how you get people to like
there's still people out here really
believing that gas station owners are
[ __ ] filthy rich just because it's
six dollars now you really think these
people are rich they're not [ __ ] rich
man yeah so um what joe's wealthy
the record yeah for oil was 140 per
barrel in june 2008 but gas prices have
gone way past where they were in 2008 i
like 2008 prices i'm right remember we
were complaining about that university
southern california professor believes
that the it's because the taxes are
higher than they were back in 2008 so
that the price of fuel you see at retail
it's not just the price of oil which is
the foundation but also includes all the
additional taxes oh
so that's what's racking up same [ __ ]
7 gas stations
like 7.95
actual cost of oil
is the same from 2008 right cheaper it's
cheaper it's actually cheaper than them
100 or 100 it was 140 per barrel in 2008
now it's like right now it's like 98. so
the the thing is taxes the red tape all
these extra like bureaucratic things and
wealthy gas stations and wow very
wealthy gas stations greedy gas station
orders
[Music]